at middle abandoned for labor with us
this morning always a pleasure to have
you on the show great to be with you
joining us uh what are we going to do if
Sudanese people could try to come to the
UK
well I think
it's much better to tackle these
problems at rude so the first priority
is obviously to get the British citizens
out
um and I'm glad the government is doing
that and this is obviously very anxious
time for the people who are there the
second priority is to work with other
countries to see if the ceasefire can be
extended
but you know the the truth about this is
that you know conflicts elsewhere in the
world do have impact on us and that's
why you need secure borders and you need
a proper system in place for dealing
with Asylum and all those things I'm
afraid the bill being debated today in
the House of Commons is not it
the German foreign minister incorrect to
criticize the British government for not
acting quicker to bring out British
citizens from Sudan well look
um this is a complicated situation and I
think as in any of this this kind of
these kind of circumstances after the
event we all want to see where there are
lessons to be learned you know
the embassy staff as I understand it
were brought out because of a specific
threat to them
the Americans as I understand it have
not yet brought out their citizens so
let's you know I'm I'm not in the
business today of getting into
criticizing the government I'm in the
business of saying we need a plan from
the government to get the predicisms out
as quickly as possible in this ceasefire
window and then after the event let's
try and learn lessons about whether
whether other whether different routes
could have been taken I understand that
but it's how helpful is it that German
foreign minister criticizing the British
government at this time well I think the
most helpful thing is to focus on the
needs of the citizens get them the
information get them out as quickly as
possible do everything we can to protect
our people who are there talk to me
about this bill that's going through the
immigration bill that is going through
Parliament at further today what aspects
of the bill does labor support
well the Bill's not going to work okay
we don't support the bill and let me
tell you why the Bill's not going to
work the bill says that anyone who comes
over on a small boat uh illegally
according to is going to be detailed
it's going to be detained and returned
right
but it's not clear whether within 28
days it's not clear where they're going
to be returned to because uh returns
return agreements haven't been but
return agreements haven't been
negotiated with some countries but not
with lots of countries
the bill only but Albania is is it the
exception not the rule that's where a
lot of people come from well that's
where some of the people come from but
lots of other people come from Iraq and
elsewhere there are other countries okay
so that's the first thing so they're
going to be returned it's not clear
where they're going to be returned to
there's no plan to deal with the backlog
of claims so a bill was passed a year
ago by the government which they said
would stop the small boats at 45 000
people came over only one percent of
those claims are dealt with so they're
now in staying in in hotels in hotels
well they haven't dealt with it though
okay thirdly this bill doesn't deal with
the criminal gangs which actually are
the source of this instead it has
gimmicks like the Rwanda policy which is
Never Gonna uh meet the the the problems
that we've face now no the people
trafficking is already a crime so you
know that that these Smugglers why don't
we invest instead of investing in Rwanda
which is not a solution why don't we
actually invest in cross-border action
to tackle these gangs at source why
don't we have a proper Fast Track
process for dealing with these Asylum
claims why aren't we actually focused on
negotiating these return agreements and
so this builds ineffective but it's also
unethical because it's actually trying
to lock up children and you've got
conservative MPS who are rightly saying
today look this isn't this isn't going
to work you know we want to stop the
small boats it's not good for our
country it's not good for the people
coming over on the small boats they're
being exploited by the people traffic
because but this is not an answer a
gimmick a con is not an answer is it
right by the immigration minister of the
immigration Minister Robert generick to
say that people coming over at
cannibalized communities and they have
different Lifestyles and values no I
mean what's the point of that I mean
what point of just sort of trying to
kind of you know stir up kind of
Divisions damaging local community but
we want to stop we want to stop the
small boats but the point is what we
want from government is not sort of you
know megaphone sort of statements we
want actual action and we haven't had
action and they've had 13 years okay and
this goes to the wider history of this
local election campaign these people
have had 13 years in power our public
services are worse our economy hasn't
grown we've got the worst cost of living
crisis in 170 years on on record we've
got the highest back tax burden in our
history no I'm not going off the point
because it's absolutely at the heart of
this local election campaign does this
does this government have real answers
to the problems these country faces or
is it all just a con a gimmick and cheap
headlines and the answer is it is that
and actually what you want is a
government that is serious with a proper
plan to deal with the problems the
country faces is he not right though to
say that um the numbers of people you
know tens of thousands of people who are
presently hoping for Asylum have not yet
got it
um are putting immense pressure on
public services yes and and yes it's a
problem and yes it's got to be dealt
with but but let's let's have a debate
about what real solutions are let's not
have a government that comes along
annually and says we've got a plan to
stop the boats when all of the evidence
is it's not going to work you know I've
looked at this in a lot of detail it's
not an answer to the problems risking
his reputation he says he will stop the
votes Are you seriously actually
actually he's not he said he's saying
I'll stop the boats but I'm not going to
tell you when right doesn't that give
you a clue okay that it is gimmickery
and a con when somebody says I'm going
to do it and you say well when are you
going to do it by and he says well I
can't tell you when it's going to happen
but I
okay okay talk to me about Diana but are
you happy to sit next to her in the
House of Commons well I think what she
said was quite wrong
um they can't be hierarchies of racism
some people are more subject to racism
than others
uh it was wrong and it she should never
have said it she's accepted she should
never have said it
I think it's right that the labor party
has taken action suspended her and
there's going to be an investigation
into it I think the tragedy is that
Diane's got actually a proud history of
you know fighting racism and being a
Trailblazer for fighting racism but what
she said was terrible are you happy to
sit in extra
of course I would sit next to her she's
into Semite what well what she said was
completely wrong uh and and unacceptable
look I know Diane well I don't think it
I don't think it's who she is actually
she said it well I knew and she
shouldn't have said it yeah yeah no and
I'm not defense and the boss is saying
she's anti-semitic what the the Kia says
it's an anti-semitic statement and I
agree and she shouldn't have said it and
absolutely she shouldn't have said it uh
and the party has got to decide what
action it takes and it's for the party
to decide so you would accept her
apology from what you're saying no uh no
it's absolutely not for me to decide
whether she's going to sit next to her
well of course I've been sitting next to
her but the point is it's a decision
this is a decision for the labor party
it's decision for the labor party to
make about whether Diane is a candidate
uh but what she said was completely
unacceptable if you were still a boss
would you let it be I'm not going into
that okay it's not for me as a labor MP
to say whether another labor MP should
be a candidate next general election
that there'll be a proper investigation
okay let me just talk to you briefly
before I let you go about your your
brief and I'm just experiencing the
wettest March for 40 years and yet we're
hearing that they're going to be host
pipe bands what's all that about well
this is about the water companies that
have been completely unregulated uh hit
by this government uh and you know this
is not going to change is it I mean the
climate is changing and so this is going
to get worse rather than better what are
we going to do about it well look I mean
we've got to adapt as a country
but the thing I'm talking about today is
something where the government promised
action another area they promised action
and have failed to uh to deliver it
which is onshore wind sure you know they
said that they would lift the ban on
onshore Wind by the end of April uh
they've completely failed to do so why
does that matter because onshore wind is
now one of the cheapest forms of power
we have uh it you did the the band that
they introduced in 2015 has raised bills
by 180 pounds a year for every family in
Britain and yet still they're not doing
anything about it and it goes to a much
bigger argument which is you know who's
going to bring the change this country
needs not a government that makes a
promise doesn't doesn't do anything
about it and so the answer on climate is
we've got to lower energy bills and the
way to lower energy bills is to have
that Sprint for Renewables like onshore
wind we've got to adapt and invest in
adaptation as a country there's also big
opportunities in relation to the jobs
that will come from tackling this
climate crisis and we've got to invest
in those but we're not doing those
things under this government and just
briefly Before I Let You Go sorry I said
that previously but definitely this time
no I'm happy to stay the demonstrators
who say onshore wind is not the right
answer what would you say to them the
public support on show end you know the
the public how the the approval ratings
of onshore Winder something that
politicians would dream of 78 of people
according to the government's own
polling support onshorewood I don't
think I've ever had a 78 approval rating
you know I mean look you know the truth
is the truth is this is incredible I'm
sure you do I'm sure you do have a 78
approval rating but the uh well anyway
we'd all dream of having the the
approval ratings that onshore wind has
78 so
um uh look this is this is actually
popular and what the government is doing
is giving into a few Tory back benches
you say well we can't have this is what
you're saying yeah I mean I think it's
people who you know yeah that they did
they just they don't get the the scale
of the challenge that we Face they don't
seem to get the uh that this is actually
another cheat you know it's nine times
cheaper to have onshore wind than it is
to have gas why why are we not doing
this as a country great question is the
prime minister ever comes on this show
I'll ask him it's always great to see
you thank you thank you very much